so in in uni we're you know first year
of university
uh in england at least we have this
thing called freshest week
where you basically go out every night
and get pissed and
very very drunk get very very drunk and
just go clubbing sounds awesome yeah so
me being
the you know socially awkward nerd that
i was back then
um i would still try to go out as much
as i could but yeah i mean
he can get tiring off you know six or
seven days of just
pure clubbing every day man that that
[ __ ] gets to you yeah
it was a lot man yeah i don't know how
people do it and then people would like
look forward to it
the next year i know i'm like i don't
know how i i feel 30
already in this in this one week of
freshers so this one night i was just in
a club
and i wasn't even that drunk because
you'd be i'd been drinking
five or six days before that yeah and so
i was just in the middle of this darn
floor
dance floor and i just had like this
epiphany i'm having a [ __ ] time i'd
rather be watching
i'd rather be watching anime right now
like i was just that one guy who just
danced in the club and just had the this
is [ __ ]
that's literally every time i go to the
club yeah i'm like i need more drinks
yeah so so instead of getting more
drinks i'm just like you know what i'm
going to [ __ ] off and go home and watch
some bloody anime
and i didn't tell anyone that i was
[ __ ] off back home
so i i go find myself like that you're
that guy in uni
yeah i'm the lone wolf don't talk to me
i just want i just wanted to watch some
anime and
what the [ __ ] am i doing in a club when
i could be watching some big fat
animated
which is exactly what i did on a t-shirt
i i
i go back to my room and as you do in
uni
you know unlike americans in in england
we have our own private rooms so we
don't dream
the thought of having to share a room
with some i'd go [ __ ] insane yeah
yeah exactly so
i have this reward to myself and as you
do i take off my trousers because
as a guy it's you're just more
comfortable in your boxes
you just are okay jeans are way too
restrictive so
take off my trousers start sitting down
turn on my laptop and put on the episode
of monogatari
the toothbrush no no it was the shower
scene with
sandra oh yeah yeah so it was like
episode two and i was really getting
into this
wait what do you mean getting yes and i
was like no no because it was more
it's more the guttery it's a good it's a
good series okay it's a good scene
i was like a little bit tipsy but i was
i was you know i was just having a good
time because you know when you haven't
watched anime in a while
and it just feels good to watch anime
after that anime drought yeah i was just
oh man this this is just a nice break
from all the drinking and clubbing and
socializing and all that stuff yeah and
as soon as it gets to the shower scene
i just hear this door creak open like
[Music]
and then i look around and then one of
my
flatmates is just staring at me and i
turn around
and it's just me and my boxers watching
and all he sees is just sendigara's
massive tits
on screen taking a shower and i try i
try to eye him up to be like
this isn't what it looks like and he
eyes me back saying oh [ __ ] this is
exactly what it looks like
you should have asserted maintain eye
contact and then i just he just closes
the door
and i'm just like okay i'm moving to
china now
he he knows he knows my secrets and then
he just never
spoke to me again